and we we've got the girls going I'm
sorry to interrupt the pain the decisive
gain now all she needs what
actually no never mind
Jennifer you if she makes a draw still
gives Talia Cervantes a chance to catch
up with her correct if she wins it's
over tournament is over no okay yes I
think we we've been here before I think
so with the reverse Scholars with the
reverse now then in that moment Talia
won and she was in the situation that
all she needed was a draw so if he said
no and so the tournament keeps going I I
refuse
what
what a contest uh
seriously you can play a career of
tournaments and not have such an
exciting playoff as we're witnessing
between these young ladies
my hat is often because and I would be
nervous and by the way Khalia better
right now after the move C4 no
my heart won't allow B3 B3 I break up
the team that pawn structure of blacks
on the queen side is really good I like
this move B3 just challenging let's go
C3
I apologize for even asking that
question of course you want to take that
point I with every fiber of my being 95
is a good move by the way Bishop takes
D5 followed by Knight takes B3 is a
threat correct so I love this move
Knight to A5 okay well let's break it
down if I go B4 Queen C2 okay I like
this move that's a good move as well
keeping the Knight
um
offsides at the moment and B4 is a
threat B4 right now is a threat
because followed by Queen takes C3
exactly and any Bishop takes I I really
wanted to recapture with the Rook she
did play Rolex C8 inviting
B4 right Knight to C4 right and then I
take on C3 I take on E3 and I hope that
I have some sort of uh compensation
which I probably don't
D3 did Jennifer and uh we have to go for
B4 now
defend that pawn on C3 right or Bishop
F6 is oh inviting no E5 pardon me there
is a queen on C7
by the way 57 seconds for Jenny for one
minute for Talia
I think
and just to remind everybody if Jennifer
wins
she's the champion it's that simple if
Talia wins
it air all flares Anew again uh D4
Bishop D4 we've seen a trade the Knight
is headed towards F5 and they're really
sure is going to go swing to G3 and
create some serious mating threats but
not only that but I'm thinking Knight E2
and gift meet upon that's that's a good
idea that C3 Pawn is really bothersome I
gotta tell you I I would really love to
get rid of it with the move Knight D4 to
E2 will Jennifer do it no
wow
things Knight to C4
1966 exactly Jennifer
and the time perhaps I can go Knight to
E5 at that point times 30 seconds 30 33
30.4 and Knight to C6 925 versus the
Saving Grace 24. call the game who's
gonna win come on dorsa Jennifer
probably her position is better her time
I mean her time right now if she Knight
C6 95 is key if she doesn't see it I
think she's much worse
E5 95 right now she needs to pay 10
seconds
Knight E5 is a tough one
look at that bus move
clean takes and she says that fun oh no
that's a problem she didn't I didn't see
she didn't see it I think and queen
takes the coronation of a champion right
now if Jennifer wins she wins
this is it guys this is going to have
five seven seconds for Talia 27 seconds
for Jennifer an exchange and a winning
position six five four a four the night
on C4 is tickling the pawn on A3 get
traded off trade off your weak Pawn
Jennifer 20 seconds Jennifer still
thinking still pondering her options
geez I don't I'm going to see two two
seconds King H2 let's go move
too slow too slow move Queen F6 I don't
even know who I'm rooting for anymore
Queen F6 seven seconds six seconds right
now oh
five seconds for Jenny for you
that's a check nice
work we know that does not help you
Queen F7 Queen F4
H4 H4 that's a mate she saw the mate and
that's the team that's game champion and
we have a champion guys oh I was so
nervous I thought that you but I thought
she had she she and then and we have a
wonderful beautifully done by Jennifer
you
that was one way of describing it so she
is a sole winner she does have a secured
place in the
2022 woman Championship
she's got a bunch of money six thousand
to ten thousand
I think she's ready for face plants
just like oh my goodness and in the
meanwhile we have more chess we do
indeed as we see in the background there
are our great congratulations to
Jennifer we'll get her in studio in time
but first let's go to the
seniors